stop this no
hello andrew
what's new um a whole lot
check this out i just invented it super
straw
so just sit here and do your thing do i
have to tuck my shirt in because
honestly that's kind of a deal breaker
let her fly
hey wait where's april
is she all right
yeah i just gave her
the day off would it be weird if i asked
for the day off
yeah no it's okay i didn't think so
hey ron
can i ask you kind of an important
question
you know like when you go to the atm
and you get money is there an actual guy
standing behind the wall who slides
dollar bills in there
no yeah this is robots oh actually you
know what i do have a serious question
in a movie predator
can you rub any kind of mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
this thermal heat signature site or is
it one ow that sucks are you hurt
oh no all good
all good
oops except for my mouth
oh whoa
five second rule
no ah come on we better get you to a
dentist
if you're gonna take a college course
andrew you should explore a new subject
broaden your horizons uh horizons are
dumb never broaden your horizons yep
just take something you're great at and
get an easy a no offense ron but
april's way sounds way easier
guitar for beginners i value a good
education so i don't want to see andy
waste his time in college
of all my co-workers he is one of a
small number whom i do not actively root
against
uh there i go getting all sappy
receptionist says she'll fit you in as
soon as there's an opening if you're all
right i'm going to head back to the park
do you know what my social security
number is or if i'm allergic to anything
i don't like corn should i put that down
or will that be confusing because i do
like candy corn
oh
ron what a mess
here let me help you all i wanted was
two hours where i got to forget that i
was a parent oh look i found all three
differences those are two completely
different pictures
pierre garcon
was a six-round pick
kali was the fourth round indianapolis
colts
know how to draft so well they really do
andy this was delicious
it's awesome huh
it's a whole new meat delivery system
thank you son
what do you say we go out to the parking
lot run a few pass plays to burn off the
calories you are an unstoppable good
idea machine
i like andy
i'm surrounded by a lot of women in this
department
and that includes the men
peyton manning reading the defense
reggie wayne
paul's corner
andy wait up house ride
thirty dollars
candy bars fifty dollars fifty dollars
god people here are so cheap april where
have you been over two phone calls came
in unimpeded we're raising money for my
college education ron
i took a second job back at my old job
do you want a shoe shine it's a hundred
dollars
laugh all you want kyle i already took
the money out your wallet
oh
good news son
you have just won
a ron swanson scholarship
i don't think so i don't remember
applying for anything andy ron swanson
scholarship
wait are you serious
stop this no
i stomp or you lose the money
why not
i like the kid and i have the money one
thing i promised myself when i buried
gold in my backyard was that i'd never
be a hoarder or a miser about it
oh dude you forgot to put a shirt on i
do it all the time it's fine i schlepped
here sweet
so uh little birdie told me it's your
birthday coming up how about a free
birthday shoe shine what did this little
birdie tell you is going to happen for
my birthday
nice try ron you're not getting anything
out of me andrew please
ron
look i love you like a father who's not
that much older than me like a young
uncle or like uh you're my camp
counselor
but we're adults so we hang out and it's
not weird you know or actually here's
what it is
you're my lacrosse coach i get it i get
it what's the point well
coach
leslie swore me to secrecy so i can't
say anything i owe her so much i can't
ruin it for her well i respect that
see you later okay not if i see you
first uncle ron
this came out
yeah
i am starving i haven't had lunch since
yesterday so i'm gonna head over to
callahan's oh no no don't go there they
totally skimp on pickles let me go to
bighead joes for you they have the most
insane burritos i don't much go for
ethnic food
trust me they have one that's called the
meat tornado
literally killed a guy last year
you had me at meat tornado
well the numbers don't lie
i'm a goofus not a gallant
been here forever
we go don't you want to get your tooth
fixed i don't know i think my tooth
looks fine just like this
well my grandmother was missing that
tooth and she was the most beautiful
woman on her oil rig
you are an adult i'm not your dad if you
want to go we can go yay
thanks ron that's why you know even
though you're not my dad
you're like a old brother to me like a
cool uncle
but old
like a grandpa
but cool
like a son
libertarianism is all about individual
liberty and it should never be defined
by the terms liberal or conservative and
communism is no good that's right big
swing and a miss yeah and what's the
word for when a few clerics are in
charge
religious oligarchy holy
i can remember things i guess
[Music]
hey keep mine rare a man after my own
heart
[Applause]
this is fun easy girls we'll be careful
miss lewis
i'm sorry
we just wanted to invite you to come
trick-or-treating tonight i think i'm a
little old can we go wrong please please
oh you can come sure we have to go buy
seven or else good can you'll be gone
sounds perfect
come on girls
what the hell just happened first day
you ready as ready as i'll ever be
oh crap i forgot my books and my
computer just pay attention to the
lecture and enjoy my first day of
college my father dropped me off
at the steel mill
he didn't think i should go to college
but i hitched a ride and rolled and
learned a lot
hope andy does too hey ron
can i ask you a question
sure
it's about april i don't like to get
involved in people's personalities i
hurt her feelings
and now she's pissed at me
i feel like if i could just explain
myself she'd understand but she's
avoiding me
it's making me miserable
april's in the hospital sick with the
flu what
i knew it
i didn't know that is she okay yeah
she's fine
you can go visit her tomorrow morning
but don't tell her i told her i won't
no no no no
come here
i'll be out here if you need me
thanks for doing this ron
when it's all said and done there were a
few mazes i cheated on also the inside
of my mouth is black and hot
so do i strip down my underwear or all
the way naked
hello diane
i'm coming home soon to relieve you give
you a little break
it's no trouble at all
i'm a parent i'm always on duty
what flavor ice cream would you and the
children like
i'm getting some for a 30 year old who
works for me so i can bring some home
for you too
you